[Music]
[Applause]
Now the Third Reply is Some of How the Most
Critical One and Some of the People Are Claiming That It's a
Complete Reputation of the
Colorado Gambit Well Certainly These Lines Are Very
Aggressive But Never the Less Black
Response  Is Pretty Dynamic As Well You're
About To See Some Of The Very Entertaining Games From
The Black Perspective And People Who Have Some
Positional Lines A I Certainly Recommend Them
Not To Go With The Colorado
Gambit Instead Of This They Can Try Simple Enough Move Which
Is  The move d6 and for
example a sample line of both sides
can run like this so white can play the move
d4 and here black can respond with the move
nf6 a classical response by white would be
nc3 where black can pin this night with
Bishop to g4 and you can analyze this line at your own also there are some
books available
in the market but personally I found out that these
lines are bit passive and black has to do a lot of
work to at least get a win out
of it so it's  Why I'm not including this
line in my rafta and that's why we're going to stick with the move
f5 Let's see some of the
critical lines of the white now so after e
cross f5 as I recommended in my previous
video that black has to play  The move d5 to
regain the f5 pawn and you can see I have highlighted
over here the most critical
response of White will be the move d4 and the
bishop to b5 but before we look at them let's see a
one side line which one time played
By My Opponent Which is the Move
g4 Well g4 Has the Simple Idea to Hang On to This
Pun in a Very Bad Manner I Should Say
and the Immediate Response Should Be the Moo h5
Attacking the Pun and Please No White Cannot
Play the A3 Other Wise  Black Will Capture This
Pawn and White Can Not Recapture So in a Way If White
Wants to Remain a Pawn A has to Take This
H Pawn and After Words Black
Will Capture the Pawn on F and There is One
Game Happens Which Runs Like This  My
opponent played the move bishop to e2 and it's quite
logical because if you just play a careless
video that he
finally wants to develop some of his
pieces and now I continue with the my piece
development so I played queen to d5 pinning that
knight so my  Opponent immediately un
pawns that with the move rook to b1 and after words
I simply play knight to f6 and here my
opponent plays bishop to g5 after some
thinking I just grab the pawn because I can see that
none of his tactics are working so
I just  Grab the Pun and Here My Opponent
Probably Acknowledging My Move and He
Played the Knight to d2 After Words I
Simply Drop My Ruk Back to a7 and Now He
Played Knight to c4 Posting His Knight on
a Wonderful Square and Here I Castle on the
Queen  side and he played queen to d2
intending to castle on the queen side as well here
I consolidate my center with the mo e5
and now he actually castling on the queen side at this
position Games Look Ruffle Balance But Can
You Believe That Only One Move
And White is losing in the next five moves It
looks impossible right but here comes the
move so the move is b5 attacking the knight and after some
thinking my opponent played knight
to h4 but after a very simple queen cross a2
I am threatening a checkmate so my opponent
decided  Have Any Time To Capture Knight White's
Response Is Pretty Much Force White Has To Play
Knight To B3 And After Words I Played The
Winning Moo Of The Game Ch Is Bishop To Be F
And It's Like A Checkmate To Queen Because
Queen Done Have Any Square  To run and only
reply left is the c3 after words the very
simple will be d cross c3 and in the
game my opponent plays queen to c2 ch dozen help at all because I
simply capture the beat
pawn a and that comes with a check and the  Only
reply left over here for White is the
queen captures b2 after word's bishop to a3 Will
lose the queen so that is one quick game which gives
you enough analysis
how you can play if your opponent plays the move g4 All you need to
do is  Play h5 and under mine the
center so now let's stick with our main move which
is the move bishop to b5 Now before we
look at bishop to b5 if your opponent plays at this
point d4 then there will be a trans
position by the side of this move  So for
example if you don't play d5 then you can grab this pawn and
after bishop to b5 you
play queen to d6 and knight to e5 we are
back to our bishop to b5 line so that is one
trans position that can happen again with
bishop.  To b5 and d5 so let's stick with this
so white plays bishop to b5 and after black
captures the pawn white immediately
moves knight to e5 and in view of
capturing that knight black has to defend the
knight and the correct way to  The defense is to
play queens after words if your opponent
plays d4 then it is again a trans
position of the df line and you need to know what you should do against this
line because this
is probably the most aggressive and the
most critical line against  The Whole
Colorado Complex Now
Before Look A to D Let's
Look at One Other Response by White
And here I have two games for you in the
first game my opponent captures this knights
and here I recapture with the king now
black is threatening to play knight to d4 so
my opponent captures this knights and after
words I recapture with the king and now he
played  The move d4 and I continue with my
normal peace development with the move g6 and the
usual moves continue like this so I
played bishop to g4 I played bishop to g7 and
after rook to e1 which has a merit of
attacking the e7 I simply defended with  The
move stops a to e8 and now in view of this
bishop is capturing this pawn my opponent has to
play the move c3 which allows me to
free up all my pieces with the move e5 and here
white's response is pretty much four so white
has  To capture this pawn and after words I
recapture this bishop and if you look at this
position it is very very dangerous for white because
not only black is threatening
to capture the white queen after bishop cross
a2 but black's two bishops are posted on very good
attacking diagonal  So in the game my
opponent has to parry this threat so he has to move his queen so he
played queen to d2 after
words I capture the h2 pawn with a
check and after king to a1 I simply snap
off the rook and after queen recapture I
plaid rooks to d8 and i don't need to go further from here on
words not only black
is a clear pawn up but black has attack to
boot and please don't forget black has a
bishop per so i finally manage to win this
game so that's  One idea if the pawn plays
knight cross
f7 in another game my opponent played a solid enough move
f and here I just
capture this knight and after only capture with
the pawn of course if the queen is captured then the
queen will be  Exchange and black position is pretty good here I played a very strong
move like
queen to g6 and idea very simple
I want to capture the c2 pawn I
can also play bishop to a3 and also black can
planning to castle on the queen side and
its  Amazing That This One Move And Black's
Position Is Very Very
Superior The Other Bad Aspect From The White Perspective
Is How White Will Going
To Save This Pawn The Answer Is He Can't Well
In The Game White Tries To Move The Pawn With The
Move c4 But  That runs slap bang in to move
bishop to d3 and for as long as I can see black will be a
clear exchange up my opponent
plays in the game queen to f3 and after
words I capture the rook and please note the
beauty about this move is  c4 Pawn a Pin So
White Can't Play See Cross d4 So in the
Game My Opponent Decided to Play Queen's
Cross d5 After Words I Simply Play Stopped
to d8 Attacking the White Queen So My
Opponent First Grab This Night and After
I Recapture So in the  View of check mating
white on jit white queen has to remain on this
file so the only move left is queen to
f3 after words the game finishes in three
moves after I played rook two
and so two sort of attacking ideas you can
get especially in queen  To the e2 line I have
covered most of the side lines that can be
played by your opponent and you can agree
with me that Black has a wonderful position. In
the next part I am going to deal intensively with what to do
again the main line
bishop to
b5